ah I'm just getting your watery
Lee was born a happy healthy baby but
when he was one a life-threatening
infection closed off his Airways and
stopped blood getting to his brain
it left him quadriplegic blind and with
severe learning difficulties he is
almost entirely reliant on his mother's
care it requires a lot of moving and
handling
lifting and moving you know on the bed
to change him get him dressed get him
washed things like that and I'm finding
that really really difficult at the
moment Tanya is among some five million
unpaid carers who contribute Clues to 8
billion hours of work each year without
them the social care system would simply
collapse
my husband is self-employed so he can't
get time off because if he does get time
off to help me with Lee then he doesn't
get paid
and that's always very difficult you
know the cost of living's going up isn't
it energy bills are rising we do
struggle with that a report commissioned
by the department for health has found
1.5 million carers provide 50 hours or
more unpaid work each week
the number receiving paid support is
falling now it's just 27 percent
and those provided with respite care has
fallen from 57 000 to 33 000. for some
the mental physical and financial
pressures are at unsustainable levels
pure and unpaid carer you have to have
the heating on for the person that you
care for you can't switch off an oxygen
machine if someone is dependent on it so
what are you doing going to food banks
or missing out on meals um yourself but
they're also propping up a social care
system which doesn't have enough staff
in it so they don't necessarily help
them when they need the respite
themselves and these Workforce shortages
are also resulting in vulnerable people
not having continuity of care the
reports authors spoke to one mother who
described how her son over the course of
two years had a 143 different carers
that's 143 people who need to be trained
each time to deal with a person with
specialized needs the department for
health says we all unpaid carers a debt
of gratitude they say plans are being
finalized to deliver a further 25
million pounds to support carers like
Tanya to care for their loved ones oh
she's Joshi Sky News